[Musique]
bonjour à tous il est 8h le journal
les scandales lactalis prend de
l'ampleur des jarres en fait mort et sow
ont été atteints salmonellose
année se termine avec ce nouveau
scandale après la découverte de viande
de cheval
une surconsommation de charcuterie et de
viandes rouges favoriserait certains
cancers c'est un coup de tonnerre une
nouvelle vidéo choquante tournée dans un
abattoir diffusé ce matin par une
association de défense des animaux
[Musique]
nouveau scandale sanitaire en europe qui
touche les eu cette fois
[Musique]
en quelques semaines on est devenus des
bourreaux on est traités quasiment
d'assassins tous les jours
on avait ce fantasme de se dire on va
toujours produire moins cher et sur des
produits alimentaires qui sont du vivant
il ya des choses qu'on peut pas
compresser
ya une tromperie quoi
on se dit on va faire notre point en
appui travail avant j'avais honte de mon
métier surtout avec toutes les
polémiques cas et maintenant j'ai appris
à aimer mon travail
ils sont les visages qu'on ne voit
jamais les rouages d'une machine qui
nous inquiète l'industrie
agroalimentaire
le système ils le connaissent de
l'intérieur
ils ont vu ces dérives vécu ces
scandales
depuis en parfum de soupçon leur colle à
la peau
pour la première fois ils ont pris le
risque de témoigner d'ouvrir les portes
parce qu'ils le savent ils vont devoir
changer parce que l'époque est en train
de basculer
on a tous la conviction qu'on est à la
fin d'un cycle qu'on est à la fin d'un
modèle
de gré ou de force un système va bouger
[Musique]
c'est l'histoire d'une abondance
trompeuses
dans le système industriel qui avait
réussi à se faire oublier
comme si la nourriture pousser tout seul
dans les rayons comme s'il n'y avait pas
d'usiné d'ouvriers pour remplir nos
assiettes
[Musique]
l'envers du décor nous commençons à
l'entrevoir
c'est un système vorace programmé pour
grossir
ils sont cinq cent mille à faire tourner
la machine tous les jours
cinq cent mille employés rien que pour
la france
l'agroalimentaire est devenue la
première industrie
c'est aussi l'une des plus dures
pas pressé aujourd'hui
à quelques kilomètres des anciennes
mines de lorraine cette usine de
surgelés fonctionne 24 heures sur 24
je m'appelle est emilie j'ai 27 ans
on métis et ouvrir de production dans
l'agroalimentaire
j'ai arrêté les études au bac j'ai eu un
petit garçon assez jeune j'ai passé mon
permis et je suis venu travailler
le matin pour venir au travail je me
lève à 4h30 pour commencer à 6 heures
je fabrique des lasers des cannellonis
des plats surgelés
marie en plus eu un côté blanc
la chaîne à partir du moment qu'elle est
réglé
c'est parti kwa l'arrêter
j'ai souvent 140 soit vraiment petit
cdja s'en rend aimable
ça donne faim
mais tu ne fasses
sur la zone
pas qu'elle dépassera 4 travers vous
retourner
moi ce sont thomas crise je m'en sois
une barquette avec la patte de travers
sa sens pas vous mais bon les gens ils
achètent donc quand même forcé
moi ça me tient à coeur ce que je suis
là je me lève tous les matins pour venir
travailler donc moi je me dis oh tough
venir et faire bien les choses en
nourrit quand même les gens donc c'est
pas un travail comme un autre quoi
trois français sur quatre manches du
surgelé
chaque jour 160 mille barquettes sorte
de ces lignes
de quoi rassasier une ville de la taille
de grenoble
ce 64ème minute complète 72
franchement il ya des jours où j'en ai
marre des voix
je pense beaucoup à ma famille qu'est ce
que mes enfants font qu est-ce que mon
mari fait à mes animaux quand je veux
rentrer si l'on fait des conneries ou
pas s'ils seront d'euros
moi je pense que le consommateur et
proxy des machines je pense parce que
moi avant de venir ici je pensais que
c'est pas des personnes qui faisait ça
ce sont deux marques est la minute
c'était pas possible
il faut du courage déjà juste pour
suivre la cadence c'est physiquement on
sent pas la moins champ plus la douleur
que je suis là je sens quand je rentre à
la maison je me dis ah j'ai mal au dos
aujourd'hui ou âgées mal à l'agent vous
pensez que c'est un métier qu'on peut
faire toute une vie
oui en a qui y en a qui l'ont fait donc
oui je pense que oui faut s'économiser
[Musique]
à
car déjà me demande ce que je fais je
commence à leur mentir je dis que je
suis dans l'agroalimentaire déjà je vois
comment réagit la personne ensuite
j'entame la conversation part je suis
anesthésiste animalier
si je vois que la réaction n'est pas
trop trop mal je continuais je prolonge
jusqu'à dire que je suis ouvrier
d'abattoir
personnellement je trouve que c'est
mieux dit que de dire je suis tueurs
d'animaux
[Musique]
je comprends les personnes que ça peut
choquer mais pour manger la viande il
faut abattre une bêta
je suis arrivé ici devoir de sa radio
2,5 au chaud c'est bon c'est quand même
quelque chose la vue l'odeur de bord des
mises à mort au début ça a été dur
je pensais pas rester même la journée et
puis au fur et à mesure
on s'habitue
c'est ici que l'animal devient viande
et de lait viande il en faut pour le
steak frites nos cordons bleus ne se si
ce cocktail
notre appétit dévore 3 millions
d'animaux par jour
sur la tâche
on oublie le côté
sacrifice
ce qui nous rassure c'est qu'on se dit
qu'on a grâce à nous ça va nourrir des
personnes
qu'on va faire mais j'ai des gens qui
sont incapables eux de le faire c'est le
sale boulot que les gens ne veulent pas
faire un gros
[Musique]
c'est de finir le plus tôt possible
parce que c'est usant physiquement mais
moralement passer quand même j'en ai vu
m'a beaucoup arriver et même pas tenir
une heure et repartir de suite
c'est pas évident qu'on côtoie tous les
jours la mort on donne de l'amour est
bon on n'a pas le choix il faut bien
travailler faut bien payer les factures
et la banque j'ai commencé à votre avis
les abattements je viens avec mon boulot
ça me permet
pouvoir le continuer en relativisant
donc
ça permet de voir se vider de
reformater on va dire le coordinateur de
reformater le cerveau
saluer vous j'ai 30 ans j'ai déjà pas
mal au mal aux mains la nuit des
malheureux au dos aussi surtout on est
en permanence en train de tirer de le
solliciter
et je pense pas qu'on fasse de bons
vieux quoique ça me fait peur et j'ai
peur de mal vieillir est justement de
peu ou pas profiter de ma retraite
j'espère y arriver ça serait bien
jour après jour le système accélère la
cadence la machine qui nous nourrissent
perfectionne
ailleurs chaque paysan avait une dizaine
de cool benjamin lui on a 200 milles
je m'appelle ballon j'ai 32 ans je suis
éleveur de poules pondeuses je produis
60 millions 2 environ par an quasiment
un oeuf pour chaque français
d'habitude ces usines vivantes
fonctionne son soleil et surtout sans
témoin benjamin nuit s'est laissé filmer
doit approcher une douzaine de
kilomètres à faire quotidiennement pour
surveiller tous les animaux ça me fait
mon sport quotidien
[Musique]
en france 2 e sur trois proviennent d'un
élevage industriel comme celui-ci
des cages à perte de vue
50 pour le parcage cinq ampoules sur 4
mètres carrés c'est peu mais c'est légal
benjamin respecte toutes les normes
la société peut être choqué et a heurté
par là la dimension des fermes en france
en neuf ou dans d'autres secteurs mais
on est obligé aujourd'hui d'atteindre
ses dimensions là pour faire un oeuf
premier prix
[Musique]
les oeufs la protéine numéro un en
france
la moins chère pour les ménages et la
plus utile pour l'industrie
[Musique]
elle engloutit des milliers de tonnes
pour fabriquer plats cuisinés aux
pâtisseries
[Musique]
l'arrivée à quelle heure
vite à paris
le camion aujourd'hui il prend 22
palettes
l'a rappelé hier après midi pour en
rajouter 2
bon mon père quand il s'est installé il
avait dix neuf mille poules et moi quand
je me suis installé trente ans après il
a fallu que j'en ai dix fois plus et ça
fait des années que je la bricole cette
machine
elle a quel âge la machine ah ben je les
ai eus en 81 16 donc tu vois un peu
honte plus de vingt ans
lorsqu'on s'est installée nous en 79
ouest france a fait une page un petit
morceau de pages
loi notre mérite lorsqu'on a fait on a
fait un agrandissement dans les années
90 on a eu pareil les l'honneur de la
presse andré était plutôt admirer par la
société benjamin et moi on est plutôt
montré du doigt par la société alors
qu'au final on fait le même le même
travail en plus en ayant amélioré la
qualité de vie des animaux par rapport à
l'époque on est bloqué dans ce système
tout ce qu'on fait est critique et il ya
30 % des agriculteurs l'an dernier qui
avait moins de 350 euros de revenus par
mois je sais pas si vous imaginez cela
pour 30% des producteurs la moyenne 1200
euros par mois pour être responsable
jour et nuit et avoir des remboursements
pharaonique je sais pas mais c'est pas
le rêve
ça a été ce système là qui nous a été
proposé et rien d'autre il fallait
absolument répondre pour les
distributeurs pour les partenaires à ce
besoin qu'avait la france en 9
issus de poules élevées en cage il y
avait bien forcément quelqu'un qui
devait endosser ce rôle de produire
toute cette nourriture
[Musique]
le système il est né sur les ruines de
la guerre
la france ne voulait plus avoir faim
l'agriculture se modernise la nourriture
ce mécanisme
[Musique]
la tâche est l'exécuteur et de nourrir
les dom cette tâche il la gombe libyen
[Musique]
la nourriture est à la portée de tous
abondance de marier les textes
[Musique]
plus qu'un magasin la grande pour pat
est devenu un lieu de promenade comme
les eaux
personne n'entrevoit les limites de ce
modèle ultra productiviste
l'ambition qu'on a posés c'était
produire de plus en plus et de moins en
moins cher
et c'était ça le montra collectif et
ça a très bien marché pendant des années
et aujourd'hui on se rend compte que ce
système là il a des effets pervers des
effets collatéraux on peut l'appeler
comme on veut mais qu'il ya un truc qui
bug parfois dépollution de la perte de
biodiversité c'est aussi des
problématiques autour des pesticides
c'est des problématiques autour des
perturbateurs endocriniens quelque part
je pense que collectivement c'est un peu
aveugle est en fait
le système est allé trop loin dans
l'avidité dans la complexité
il a mis sous tension ces salariés s'est
produit
et ce qui devait arriver arriva
m
sur ces chaînes emilie n'a pas vu venir
le scandale
c'était en 2013
leboeuf qui lui passe entre les mains
est en réalité du cheval
la sphère des lasagnes fait la une
l'entreprise d'emilie plaide la bonne
foi et affirme que c'est son fournisseur
spanghero qui l'a trompée
mais du jour au lendemain l'usiné
boycotter
la première semaine on a continué à
tourner normalement que ce qu'on avait
des commandes quand même à terminer puis
petit à petit les lignes se soit arrêtée
une après l'autre on était même au
chômage technique pendant des semaines
et des semaines entières j'ai pensé je
vais perdre mon travail je viens
d'acheter ma maison
comment qu'on va faire quoi
reposent
[Musique]
les jours pourquoi tu sais plus quel
jour où ses manies kim jin et jours
mariam dîner jours derniers de quoi la
semaine d'après
vous pouvez différencier le porc du
boeuf mais le cheval du boeuf non puis
même au bout
nous on goûte toutes les heures on n'a
jamais rien goûter de blizzard
franchement ça change herrero n'a jamais
eu de thil je trouvais dans les
barquettes elle était bonne même très
bonne 700 le pire de tout ça a été
vraiment un choc on était
on était perdus moi j'étais perdu et les
personnes se sont sentis trahis
avec cette histoire c'est normal quand
on l'a dit à la réunion où je suis a
pleuré
j'ai pleuré parce que j'avais peur hein
que l' usine fermée j'avais peur
pour moi pour mes collègues
de travail qu'on a failli perdre usine à
c'est bien simple moi personnellement
pour moi ça a été exagéré
moi j'aurais été consommatrices alors
plein soit j'aurais mangé quelque chose
qui qui n'était pas marqué sur la
barquette oui j'aurais été déçu c'est
normal je les comprends ça peut arriver
oui mais
[Musique]
on
en fait quand le scandale de la viande
de cheval est arrivé
nous on a eu plein de questions au
service consommateurs qui ont demandé si
on était concerné
mais c'est pas ça qui est intéressant ce
qui est intéressant c'est que la
deuxième question c'est est qu'est ce
que vous mettez dans votre / amy la
troisième c'est question c'est comment
vous fabriquez votre jambon en fait ce
scandale là
ça peut être été
c'était pas un scandale sanitaire mais
c'était le scandale de trop sur la
confiance
c'était une façon de prendre en pleine
figure que
on pouvait affirmer quelque chose et
faire le contraire
david travaille pour le leader français
du jambon
sa marque aussi a souffert certains
consommateurs n'ont pas digéré
on se fait interpeller en permanence en
fait par des gens qui sont convaincus
qu'on fait pas assez qu'on va pas assez
vite qu'on achète pas assez de produits
en france conte
très pas suffisamment bien les animaux
bonjour je viens pas facile de vendre
dans un tel climat pour regagner la
confiance il faut affronter les
critiques et répondre à tous les
courriers
là il ya une dame notamment ktk vul mais
le reportage à la télé hier soir et sur
les nitrites et c'est vraiment très
émotionnel dit donc quand vous dites sur
votre site que vos produits sont sans
danger c'est faux vous pensé qu'à
l'argent vous voulez absolument nous
emprisonner je vous conseille d'arrêter
de vous [ __ ] de nous consommateurs
allaient très violente 1 là c'est un
monsieur qui nous dit j'aimerais savoir
si vos ports sont élevées en plein air
est sinon pourquoi j'ai vu qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui se plaint des pizzas mais
comment tu lui réponds puisqu'on ne
fabrique pas des pizzas
on lui dit aussi simplement titian le
nez on les dit que bon on fait pas
bizarre mais celui-là il dit pour
obtenir vos tranches de jambon vous avez
financé la déportation la séquestration
la mutilation le viol d'êtres vivants
c'est
là c'est que ça devient compliqué mais
on va lui répondre quand même
l'information qui était jusqu'alors
l'apanage des marques et c'était des
marques qui distillait l'information est
souvent à leur avantage sur le
reconnaître parce que c'est une approche
marketing et bien cette information elle
et elle est devenue disponible grâce à
internet grâce aux réseaux sociaux moi
je suis impressionné de voir par exemple
des consommateurs qui aujourd'hui font
l'information alors parfois les fausses
c'est le problème parfois les fausses
dans tous les cas qui peuvent vérifier
et qui peuvent maintenant traiter d'égal
à égal
c'est une défiance qui inquiète
l'ensemble des acteurs de la filière
parce qu'on se dit que
à horizon 20 ans si on change arrière on
sera plus lent
[Musique]
le système un talon d'achille qui
pourrait précipiter ces chutes les
animaux
[Musique]
on les traite comme une matière première
utile en charcuterie comme en confiserie
mais aujourd'hui le consommateur
supporte mal leur souffrance
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il derrière les murs des
abattoirs français une nouvelle vidéo
accablante a été réalisé et diffusé
certains abattoirs qui revendique par
ailleurs la certification bio
l'opinion a basculé avec ces images
depuis 2015 l'association l214 film des
abattoirs en caméra cachée
on y voit des ouvriers soumettre les
animaux à une agonie longue et violente
[Musique]
l'abattoir de romain n'a pas été
épinglés mais ces vidéos ont marqué les
esprits
et moi le premier j'ai été choqué j'ai
vu ces images
pour moi ça ne devrait pas exister c'est
une personne qui fait ça c'est une
personne et qui aime pas à son travail
et quand j'ai vu c'est gilles ces images
il dit qu'est ce qu'on va pas laisser de
deux mois et puis j'ai un fils il est
petit il a trois ans mais qu'elle va
rentrer au collège qu'on écrit
profession des parents j'ai pas envie
qu'il soit la risée ou de la casse ou
qu'on se fiche de lui parce que son papa
travers d un abattoir ou qui passe pour
un bourreau pour un fou un inculte
c'est ça principalement quoi j'ai pensé
à mon image aussi
les petits haut niveau
je l'accompagné dans le fameux couloir
de la mort comme on dit juste avant le
piège si je vois que les braves qui
aiment ça un petit peu voilà ça me coûte
quoi diffère une petite caresse je fais
pas un bisou non plus mais c'est ma
maman ma seule façon de toute façon de
lui montrer mon respect
[Applaudissements]
après je pense aussi que le système n'a
pas aidé au niveau des cadences eu trop
élevés n'ont pas aidé et le rendement
c'est ça qu'a dû inciter les gens à
devenir un peu des bourreaux à vouloir
avancer toujours plus vite
ça me pensais que la base et à la bête
animal
[Musique]
voilà messieurs merci merci moi j'ai vu
des images c'est vrai c'est vrai que
c'est il ya certains des images qui sont
choquantes les images qui sont
choquantes que les mecs que les gars
qu'ils fassent ça soit passé au tribunal
l'abattoir fermé et compagnie ça peut
qu'on brade ans après
c'est pas parce qu'il ya des images que
c'est partout tels que c'était mon
esprit c'était pas bien beau mais
l'image ne reflète pas toujours
complètement la réalité de ce qui se
passait et ça peut être un travesti et
c'est ce que justement d'en discuter
entre nous on s'est rendu compte que
certaines choses étaient telles que tout
était enfin des choses étaient à rouen
je sais pas ce que tu veux dire au
revoir mais ils ont cueilli oui il y
avait des choses à améliorer et chez
vous ça n'est pas le contraire elle
avait peut-être été négligents sur
certaines choses
mu mais par contre c'était présenté
d'une manière complètement tendancieuse
de quoi leur but c'est que tout le monde
devienne légal maintenant il faudrait
alors expliqué aux lions d'aller bouffer
du manioc au lieu d'être déçu l'antilope
ça m'étonnerait quand même que le lion
il anesthésique enveloppe apparente de
la deûle à dézinguer ou après chacun
fait comme il faisait ses lagons choisi
le pas manger de viande ou
il faut s'occuper le moment tous autant
qu'on est on a tous eu des animaux à la
maison les amis les animaux mais on
n'est pas des barbares non plus
après le steak haché voilà il faut
savoir que le steak haché mais
abandonner gambader dans un prix oui
certes mais maintenant peut-être manger
moins de viande mais manqué aussi de
meilleure qualité c'est à la mode
aujourd'hui bon maintenant pareil dans
trois quatre ans tout le monde s'en
remettre à la viande c'est peut être que
de passage on verra bien
au moment donc en nombreux à manger
et on va pas s'arrêter
tous les consommateurs aujourd'hui
s'interrogent sur leur sur leur
consommation alimentaire en général et
en particulier sur leur consommation de
viande aujourd'hui
[Musique]
60% de nos ventes c'est de la
charcuterie et on se dit que peut-être à
20 ans ce sera 40 % voire 20% voire
peut-être 0 mais c'est pas grave ce qui
compte c'est que on puisse être là pour
apporter les solutions qui correspondent
aux enjeux du moment aux attentes des
consommateurs et qui nous permettent
tous collectivement de survivre
[Musique]
non
oh
quand on surveille nos animaux quand on
déambule dans nos couloirs on peut avoir
le tournis des fois et c'est parfois
troublant
[Musique]
six heures tous les matins du lundi au
vendredi notre environnement et figurez
vous que les français sont soucieux du
bien-être des poules oui après carrefour
monoprix système u c'est maintenant
intermarché qui a décidé de supprimer de
ses rayons les eaux provenant d'élevages
en cage
la grande distribution a dit stop les
eaux de benjamin disparaîtront des
rayons en 2020
l'éleveur va perdre son principal
débouché alors qu'il a un emprunt de 2
millions et demi d'euros à rembourser
si demain tout s'arrête le système ne
tient plus tout va s'écrouler quoi c'est
l'équipe financier sera
ne sera plus possible
on peut pas imaginer que des gens est
sérieusement pris ses positions là
sans en mesurer les conséquences
et
du coup tu as les petits papiers si nice
ça c'est le récapitulatif des ans
ça c'est ce qui nous reste
à amortir
sur l'élevage et donc on a vendu la
production jusqu'ici
au delà de cette date
c'est tellement brutale on en est même
incrédule quand tu peux pas tu peux pas
croire ce qui se passe quoi
des buts 2020 nous restera quasiment un
million d'euros à rembourser à la banque
donc un million d'euros c'est pas c'est
pas possible de
gérer les dettes
à
endosser sur la tête une seule famille
alors on s'est dit vente maintenant bas
vendre maintenant je dois maintenant il
faut trouver un acheteur l'acheteur on
va pas le trouver même en vendant la
maison
l'élevage de veaux aux héros c'est
tellement brutale et c'est tellement
irresponsable comme comme décision que
moi j'en suis souvent à me dire
il ya pensé que j'espère que tous les
éleveurs qui sont dans notre cas en
sortiront vivants
on engager nos proches dedans et on se
dit que non seulement nous on va plonger
mais on va faire plonger aussi les gens
qu'on aime et ça ce n'est pas que c'est
le plus dur
c'est le plus dur à supporter quoi
je suis pas rare que bouté sur mes
positions je veux bien entendre qu'il
faille évolué qui file peut-être même
arrêter complètement le secteur va
forcément bougeait pas forcément
répondre à la demande pas forcément
mettre les poolers
mais par contre ouais on a on a oublié
de respecter l'humain et de penser aux
éleveurs
[Musique]
en france il y à plus de 30 millions de
poules en cage
pour satisfaire la grande distribution
il faudrait les mettre dehors
pas si simple
avec sa coopérative benjamin ans à
tourner le problème dans tous les sens
l'exploitation s'arrête juste derrière
le bâtiment 4 celui qui est là bas donc
combien tu restes surface possible à
côté de moi aujourd'hui sur le sur la
ferme j'ai simplement les trois hectares
sur lesquels sont posés les bâtiments
donc pratiquement j'ai même pas un
hectare de disponible si on imaginait
sortir toutes les poules il faudrait au
moins 100 ha tombe et là les terres qui
sont ici sont acquis les terres qui sont
ici à un voisin mais elles sont pas
disponibles à la vente c'est quelque
chose dont on a discuté mais qui est pas
envisageable
pour benjamin l'équation est impossible
à moins que la grande distribution ne
revienne sur le calendrier annoncé il ne
pourra ni évoluer ni remboursés si je
suis en colère c'est envers l'absence de
position de tous les intervenants du
secteur quoi
le distributeur a une position qui est
un peu cynique et qui est malsaine parce
que ils savent parfaitement ce qui est
ce que ça induit leur leur décision et
le politique est complètement absent le
politique n'intervient pas
quelque part il fait pas son boulot
[Musique]
le vieux système ne disparaîtra pas sans
faire de victime
chacun cherche à s'adapter et la
bataille est féroce
elle se joue déjà dans nos supermarchés
[Musique]
quand je suis dans des régions comme ça
je suis comme un fou jeu
j'adore regarder les derniers produits
les innovations les astuces marketing
qui sont utilisés ou pas
6 voilà je
ma femme généralement leurs proches du
passé beaucoup de temps
[Musique]
nouveaux goûts nouveaux formats nouveau
logo
comment reconnaître les bonnes volontés
parmi les fausses promesses
comment ne pas se perdre dans les rayons
c'est une jungle avec des milliers de
références
[Musique]
le jambon par exemple ultra rentable
ultra concurrentiel
je pense qu'on est arrivé à une étape où
il ya aujourd'hui un peu trop de choix
il faut rationaliser cette offre-là est
montrée beaucoup plus clairement les
différences qui a entre les produits ça
c'est un des derniers produits qu'on a
lancé c'est un jean bond sans
antibiotiques issus d'animaux nourris
sans ogm là on raconte quelque chose qui
est pas très facile en fait hein parce
que quand on a lancé ce produit on a eu
beaucoup de questions à la fois en
interne et de la part des consommateurs
qui nous ont dit si celui là il est sans
antibiotiques et sans ogm ça veut dire
que les autres en ont pour nous c'était
un vrai dilemme parce que
c'est ça voulait dire qu'on pouvait
faire prendre le risque à grande partie
de notre offre mais on a fait quand même
le choix de le faire parce qu'on s'est
dit si on veut faire évoluer les choses
la seule façon de montrer aux gens qu'il
ya une différence de la mettre sur la
table
avec un caddie nous avons tous nos
contradictions david aussi
l'industriel était également
consommateur est bien qu'il fasse partie
du système il s'en méfie
sage aschens à la presse que je fais
c'est que je regarde la liste des
ingrédients il ya du
351 du 452 du 471 du 222 moi quand je
fais un croque-monsieur jeu mais pas des
comme ça en fait donc ça ça me
en fait il est partout dans ce truc je
suis aussi
[Musique]
pas victime mais je suis j'ai pas été
assez attentifs au fait en fait ça
perturbe beaucoup là parce que je suis
là je te fais manger à mes enfants donc
je me dis que j'ai pas bien filmé entre
nous on avr ça fait 30 ans qu'on
travaille sur ce sujet là il ya un
additif qui reste problématique dans nos
produits c'est sur le jambon c'est le
250 qui est le nitrite de sodium
mais dans le reste on a réussi à les
enlever partout quoi
il ya aucun e dans celui-là par exemple
est celui là c'est celui de la marque
distributeur
il y à des paradoxes plein au rayon
même un professionnel comme david peut
s'y perdre le plus cher n'est pas
toujours le meilleur et ce qui devrait
nourrir parfois nous détruit alors là
par exemple je choisis celui là parce
que il ya deux mois dans je crois que
c'était que choisir j'ai lu un test
comparatif et dans le produits que
j'achetais j'ai vu qu'il y avait des
traces de pesticides
il était hyper bon ce produit mais moi
manger des pesticides en même temps que
et dans les produits bio qui était dans
le test y avait pas de pesticides donc
j'ai changé de marque faute il faut en
permanence réadapter son jugement et des
choses qu'on sait aujourd'hui qu'on
savait pas ya dix ans et des choses
qu'on saura demain qu'on sait pas
aujourd'hui est le seul truc qu'on peut
reprocher aux industriels sait s'ils
savent quelque chose et qui font pas
changer leur offre là il ya quelque
chose qui va pas
[Musique]
nous voulons tous que l'agriculture
s'améliore que l'industrie change
mais nous oublions que le système c'est
nous
il est la somme de nos habitudes et les
le miroir de nos contradictions
et il ne changera pas
si nous ne bougeons pas nous mêmes
lusine d'emilie a survécu au scandale
des lasagnes
l'entreprise a changé de nom renforcer
ses contrôles et regagner ses clients
mais pour plaire il faut toujours
inventer de nouvelles recettes faire
plus naturelle sans nuire aux goûts
c'est un peu la quadrature de l'assiette
[Musique]
si on prend une nazan chèvre non claasen
chexbres et fait du fromage de chèvre
fromage de chèvre affiner une avec du
des chèvres qui mange pas la même chose
tout au long de l'année on va avoir des
réclamations aujourd'hui en nous disant
votre lasagnes cher à plus e woods chef
hier ben qu'est ce qu'on doit faire
industriel où on est convaincus qu'une
hazen cher aux règles du chai du fromage
de chèvre venant de chèvres peut varier
en fonction des saisons ou alors on vous
dirige vers un fromage de chèvre qui est
standardisée qui est moins naturel mais
par contre qu'il sera toujours régulier
on pourrait rapidement basculé pour
répondre à une demande consommateurs le
consommateur aujourd'hui se veut pas
dire qui doit se taire mais se plaint
tout le temps
le chèvre être au chèvre le chèvre et
pas assez cher la tomate trop tomates la
tomate pas à ces tomates et un moment
donné ça on ne sait pas répondre à ça
donc sinon on exactement sur le même le
même produit que qu'il ya c'est le taux
de sel qui a été adapté sur la première
version on est à 1 % et là on est
descendu à 1 08 d'accord
il faut jongler entre ce qu'on a envie
de faire ce qu'on voudrait ce qu'on
voudrait faire et les exigences de nos
clients et évidemment on a toujours
quand même un peu cette contrainte cette
contrainte prix qui fait qu' on est
obligé de jongler avec les matières et
les pourcentages incorporés dans les
recettes si on prend une lasagnes
bolognaises que tout le monde connaît
on fabrique de pâtes fraîches nous
industriels c'est pas un gros mot
fabrique notre pâte fraîche on achète la
tomate on achète de la viande qu'on va h
et on achète de l'emmental on va faire
une lasagne nous on vend un produit
comme celui-là moins cher que le prix de
votre baguette ou de votre petit café
noir du matin il est nécessaire que le
consommateur ait une prise de conscience
se dire si à un moment donné je veux
manger mieux je dois accepter de payer
quelques centimes plus cher à produire
[Musique]
manger mieux vaste programme en mai qui
doit faire l'effort
le consommateur en payant plus cher ou
l'industriel en baissant ses marges
pour les petits salaires les bons
produits sont hors de prix tous les prix
explosent de tous en tout les téléphones
minéraux paquets de pâtes maintenant ce
presque à noro donc ça devient cher donc
hui les gens et ils se rabaisse il
essaye de prendre le moins cher ce qui
est tout à fait normal parce que moi je
fais ça que moi je fais pas trop
attention je mange pour manger et ce qui
a je ne prends pas trop la tête
[Musique]
non j'aime mieux ça ne coûte pas
forcément plus cher ça s'apprend
le beau père d'emilie fait son jardin il
a la main verte et arrive presque et se
passer des supermarchés
mais il a du mal à sensibiliser la jeune
femme
et ça c'est quoi le truc rond
ça s'il gauche est ce assez gauche est
passée une courgette anneaux
moi perso j'aime pas trop faire à manger
après je fais des hangover au micro
ondes ça va vite
où les pizzas en fort
ce qui sûr c'est que tu les rapaces pas
tu vas comme cela sur les sources est qu
ils sont 5e à six jours je t'ai mis
qu'un 17 alors vous mettre les des
jeunes et cela sur les autres ce qu'on
fait nous mêmes on sait ce qu'on a aussi
est-ce que ce qu'on fait on sait d'où ça
vient van dyck skier
dans le marché on ne sait pas alors on
n'a pas vu un peu et j'ai des animaux ce
serait peut-être les solutions mais tout
le monde ne va pas s'improviser paysans
demain
quand on dit industries agroalimentaires
les gens pensent élevages industriels et
c'est pas rassurant pourtant c'est une
publicité d'un genre nouveau
pour une fois le numéro un du jambon ne
montre pas ses produits mais ces
éleveurs avec une proposition choc
maintenant si vous avez toujours des
doutes venez vérifier par vous même on
vous attend
bonjour
ouvrir ses usines et ses élevages
le groupe de david a été le premier à
oser
ce matin il accueille une quinzaine de
consommateurs
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous on est
vraiment ravis de vous accueillir il ya
énormément de questions qui se posent
sur sur l'alimentation on s'est dit
finalement que la meilleure façon
c'était d'abord de se parler et puis
surtout ne pas essayer de vous raconter
une belle histoire mais de vous montrer
les choses telles qu'elles sont je pense
que certains d'entre vous pensent
peut-être qu'ils vont voir les loups la
cuisse j'espère qu'à l'issue de cette
cette visite on pourra reparler du sujet
ensemble et que vous aurez un autre un
autre regard c'est que vous enlevez vos
chaussures et puis ensuite vous mettrez
la combinaison
[Musique]
j'ai beaucoup d'à priori je ne consomme
plus de jambon depuis depuis des années
donc intéressé pour savoir si si la
démarche visuel publicité correspond
bien la réalité
le confronter à la réalité
c'est quelque chose de très inédit de
faire venir les consommateurs dans les
usines parce que pendant des années on
s'est dit faites nous confiance et
acheter nos produits on s'est retrouvés
un peu
finalement pris à notre propre jeu en
montrant des images qui étaient
magnifiques hyper léché des belles
laitières ou des des artisans d'un autre
monde en fait quand on a collectivement
vendu martine à la ferme montrer ce
qu'on fait depuis 20 ans c'est compliqué
ce sont les salles de maternité donc
avec des langues chaussons
oui bloquer non c'est pour gérer
justement les écrasements et pour
permettre à
beaune allaitement
elle elle passe à l'abattoir
on les a invités à venir vérifier mais
en fait ils découvrent
une vie à manger du jambon et pourtant
certains n'avaient jamais vu de cochon
en chair et en os 6 malgré qu'on
comprenne qu'elle soit raisonnée pour
pas blesser les petits je me dis punaise
c'est quand même des bêtes qui vont
rester statique plusieurs jours
plusieurs semaines et
s'appelle un peu quand même
[Applaudissements]
un environnement plus agréable pour elle
parce qu'elles vont avoir la possibilité
de se déplacer plus soit
bon jamais dehors alors pourquoi ils
vont jamais dehors c'est toujours la
même chose c'est pour gérer au maximum
le sanitaire
on va passer à la suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
il y avons tué le cochon dans les fermes
aujourd'hui cette usine xxl fournit
toute la france
fabrique 100000 jambes on sent vite j'en
sors mes jambes ont cinquante mille
cochons par semaine
[Musique]
c'est gigantesque en fait quand on voit
le nombre d'animaux que ça représente
derrière
[Musique]
la filière qu'il faut pour arriver à
fournir
zuma
vertige devant la taille du système mais
aussi devant ces gestes simples
aujourd'hui oubliée là on va vous
montrer comment des eaux sage en mots
et l'opération de désossage a consisté à
enlever en fait tout ce qu'on veut pas
retrouver dans le produit final
notamment le gras consommateurs il veut
un produit qui soit plus maigre possible
les consommateurs avaient voulu la
transparence les voici à la fois
désenchanté et rassurer
derrière leurs tranches de jambon une
machine efficace et une hygiène
draconiennes
mais ce qu'ils ont vu n'est qu'un
maillon du système
[Musique]
des doutes on aura toujours sachant que
c'est une expérience ponctuelle et que
ça c'est pas représentatifs de la
globalité en fait ça nous dit pas que
maintenant supermarché on ne trouvera
que des produits qui tendent vers là on
sent bien qu'ils aient encore énormément
de démarches à faire et qu'on en est au
début de quelque chose
les gens ne sont sortis de là en me
disant j'ai compris des choses je vous
fais pas 100% confiance pour autant
parce que j'imagine que vous avez encore
plein de choses à faire et j'espère que
vous allez les faire mais ça veut dire
qu'on est en train de
deux au moins réussir une chose c'est de
réussir à renouer le dialogue
c'est un premier pas mais la route est
longue et la communication ne suffira
pas
[Musique]
le système doit faire sa révolution
pour nous convaincre l'industrie mise
sur le bio
du naturel en quantité industrielle
on a 300 petites maisons pour les
cochons
il y à un abri et un terrain pour chaque
fruit
donc au total on a 50 km de clôture
le danemark et le royaume du cochon bio
c'est ici que le leader du jambon vient
se fournir
[Musique]
pour les quantités la france n'arrive
pas à suivre il y a encore trop peu
d'éleveurs convertis
c'est ce qu'on aimerait voir partout en
fait ça ressemble plus à ce que mon fils
il voit dans son livre de martine à la
ferme que ce qu'on voit dans les
élevages qu'on a développés
collectivement depuis 50 ans
en fait on se dit que si on peut
contribuer à développer plutôt des
modèles de ce type là que des modèles en
bâtiment même s'ils peuvent être
extrêmement efficace il ya aussi un sens
qui est donné à notre métier on se dit
qu'on sert à
aussi à favoriser les bonnes pratiques
en fait
[Musique]
je
je pense que le consommateur souhaite
améliorer son alimentation il se
préoccupe des conditions d'élevage de
bien-être animal de ce que l'animal a à
manger de la manière dont les produits
ont été transformés et là il faut dire
les choses telles qu'elles sont ça va
coûter plus cher mais donc il y aura des
arbitrages à faire au niveau du
consommateur peut être mangé de la
viande un peu moins souvent mais de
meilleure qualité oh
c'est pas vrai mais superbe
moi je vais immortaliser ce moment
c'est pas vrai et bon vent très beau je
pense que ce serait très dangereux si
l'industrie dit on a changé croyez nous
sur parole il faut pas la croire sur
parole il faut la mettre à l'épreuve et
il faut qu'elle soit en capacité de
démontrer ce qu'elle fait que c'est
sincère qu'il ya un vrai mouvement en
même temps si l'industriel bouge c'est
est-ce que c'est pas le la plus belle
des victoires collectives peut pas se
fait dire qu'il ya un problème et quand
l'industrie bouge se dire que c'est
n'importe quoi ce système
on peut pas le nier connu des dérives on
a vu des images on
connus des scandales des contaminations
et
peut-être on va abandonner ce système
mais est ce que demain les autres
systèmes vont nous garantir de ne plus
avoir de scandale de ne plus avoir de
maltraitance de ne plus avoir de
contamination
y arias qui est moins sûr que ça
je mange tu manges nous mangerons
trois fois par jour la question revient
et reviendra
demain les scandales ne vont pas
disparaître par magie
mais on peut espérer manger mieux
[Musique]
c'est notre intérêt à tous
industriels commerçants consommateurs
dans l'assiette c'est notre société qui
se décide
[Musique]
en